fin avril en périphérie de berlin un
véhicule pas très officiel fait son
arrivée pour une soirée de gala à mon
explication la star qui en descendent ce
n'est pas cette élégante jeune femme
mais son chauffeur en basket jaune
flashy
et quelqu'un pour ma voiture
mike horn l'explorateur est venue avec
sa fille annick à ce spécialiste de la
survie et des grands espaces va se plier
à un exercice auquel il n'est pas
habitué les mondanités
ce soir c'est la soirée des laureus
award qui consacre les sportifs de
l'année et les convives sont plutôt au
collet monté
mc je te présente pascal notre nouveau
pilote ravi de rencontrer
mike retrouve des connaissances comme
nico rosberg
le champion de formule 1
vous avez toujours une longueur d'avancé
avec la voiture à wayne la voiture est
incroyable c'est un vrai plaisir plus
loin la star mondiale du tennis le serbe
novak djokovic
entre le tennisman et l'aventurier pas
facile d'avoir quelque chose à se
raconter alors ils parlent de leurs
baskets j'adore tes chaussures ouais
merci très très bon choix de couleurs
oui elles sont incroyables elle est en
soi plus tard devant la meute de
photographes
mike doit forcer un peu sa nature et
prendre la pose
qu'ils soient pas aussi nombreux à se
déplacer au pôle pour te prends en photo
anja paerson cole avait comme j'arrive
au pool la personne ces enjeux d'en
prendre celle ci
mike est membre du jury tout comme
marcel desailly le champion français de
football pour qui les exploits de
l'aventurier n'ont plus aucun secret
coller toutes ces histoires de la fourmi
en amazonie ça semble pouvoir traverser
la rivière parce que de l'autre côté il
ya un feu il ya et toutes sortes de
choses des pirates c'est un personnage
unique quand on prend le temps un peu on
s'aperçoit que c'est absolument unique
ce qui vit ce qu'il a vécu ce qui ce
qu'ils échangent à 50 ans mike horn est
un ovni dans le monde du sport loin des
podiums et des tapis rouge pour lui pas
de championnat c'est avec les éléments
qu'il est en compétition
tout commence de l'autre côté de la
planète dont son pays natal l'afrique du
sud durant son service militaire il
intègre les forces spéciales et à 19 ans
il part faire la guerre en angola dans
la brousse le jeune lieutenant voit ses
camarades mourir les uns après les
autres de là lui viendra un instinct de
survie hors du commun en 1997 il défie
le plus grand fleuve du monde et des
sons l'amazone en hydrospeed mais il
veut aller plus loin un tour du monde en
suivant la ligne de l'équateur une
première trois océans et plus de 40000
km en solitaire en totale autonomie et
rien étanche sa soif de conquête pas
même les plus hauts sommets du monde
qu'il gravit son oxygène
à ce jour seul le mon cas de en himalaya
lui résiste aujourd'hui il est devenu
une icône de l'aventuré il s'en est même
fait une spécialité à la télévision que
ce soit en tant que conseiller en survie
pour ce programme de télé réalité copé
en bouche sans machette c'est pas facile
c'est pour ça j'ai cassé m pierre ou ici
avec le comédien michaël youn pour qui
il va jouer les guides de randonnées
extrême dans une adaptation de
l'émission américaine running wilde
on va monter les montagnes on va marcher
au père ça n'a marché et salués il
semaine en enfer tout fait comme ça
houle aventuriers pouces sont invités à
bout
après 25 ans passés à risquer sa vie
dans les pires endroits du monde mike
horn en redemande ils s'apprêtent encore
une fois à flirter avec ses limites
dans le canton de vaud chez lui à
château-d'oex en suisse l'aventurier
s'accordent une petite pause il y à 25
ans que l'enfant de johannesbourg est
venu s'exiler ici
allez on y va
on vit un peu oui
regarde
partout
dans l'es10 il ya les logements vides
le vainqueur est la montagne a envie de
sauter dans des rivières envie d'aller
courir dans les bois
au village il retrouve son frère martin
avec sa petite famille
pour sa prochaine expédition autour du
monde et rien n'est encore prévu mais
l'explorateur aimerait que son petit
frère s'occupe cette fois encore de
l'organisation
ils essayent de vous convaincre de le
suivre exactement non mais c'est bon
c'est mon expérience
ça marche bien en fait en famille parce
qu'on a l'habitude de travailler avec et
puis c'est aussi ça qui rentrent
l'exposition plus facile c'est compliqué
quand dijon sait pas quoi faire compte
il doit faire quelque chose lui martin
et ça fait bosser 20 en 20 ans avec moi
et puis lui depuis latitude zéro c'était
lui qui était responsable de ramener nos
bateaux l'autre côté du continent
cependant je traverse et il a fait plus
beaucoup plus un avion il avait beaucoup
plus que moi
la suisse c'est la base arrière de la
famille horn ici les deux frères venus
d'afrique du sud ont refait leur vie et
sur la place du village il ne passe pas
inaperçu
le père de mes premières pâtissier il
était habilité comment bac est il arrivé
elle est un peu plus timide
[Applaudissements]
et après on l'a après la fait une
journée comme ça on fait remarquer
nadine en moi je veux faire comme eux du
rafting non c'était là il était déjà
comme ça quoi simplement le connaissais
pas mais la tchaux été comme ça
les montagnes suisses ne lui suffisent
pas mike horn voit plus grand
c'est le plus gros défi de mike
certainement le plus fou de sa carrière
un tour du monde en 360 jours avec
notamment une traversée à skis de 6000
km du continent antarctique un voyage
entre l'épaule dans un enfer de mer et
de glace que l'explorateur par réaliser
sans assistance
[Musique]
dans un coin de la vallée l'aventurier
s'est fait construire une petite cabane
est là où monsieur tout le monde
stockent sa tondeuse ou sont taillés
my contre pause d'où les équipements de
ses 25 ans d'exploration
c'est un peu sa caverne d'ali baba
[Musique]
l'ag prépare en fait
matière elle pour aller au
repos sud
et quand on s'apprête à traverser
l'antarctique à skis mieux vaut prévoir
un bon couchage
savoir moins 60 c'est du sur mesure à
7000 euros le duvet
même même la dent avec toutes ses plumes
et tout ça tu as moins 18 degrés te
reste juste juste vivant
-18 la limite mois 18 c'est la limite
ouest chaque deux heures tu dois te
réveiller parce que ici au fond du sac
il ya très peu d espace et têtu gel pour
éviter les engelures la bouillotte quand
on est dans la tente on a une bouteille
exprès pour faire pipi et sage je m
intéresse de mon sac de couchage vers
mes pieds essart chauffe mes pieds pour
ses expéditions mike conçoit lui-même
ses équipements dont les moindres
détails c'est du matériel que tu trouves
que ici ça existe nulle part ailleurs au
monde et ça ça me donne beaucoup de
plaisir
ça va du thermos renforcé à la casserole
qui fait chauffage pour la tente du haut
de pyjama spécial pôle sud jusqu'aux
short molletonné avec coutures
thermocollé grâce à tout son matériel il
a pu traverser le pôle nord de nuit du
jamais vu
pendant deux nuits et effet une fois
dans l'histoire de notre planète et à
plus de gens qui a marché sur la lune
pareil pour l' aventure il a déjà des
fourmis dans les jambes
[Musique]
pourtant il y a un nom mike a failli
renoncer à tous ces projets à la mort de
sa femme cathy des suites d'une longue
maladie il perd le goût de l'aventuré
j'ai eu presque envie de partir parce
que c'était
la moitié de l'expédition est plus là
parce que la moitié était quartier et
l'autre moitié était moi elle me donnait
la liberté des partis mais un échange
elle me demandait de rentrer vivant
c'est un seul petit truc son aile il se
retrouve seul face à ces défis quand je
disais mais je trouve ma vie avec la
tienne elles me disent non je veux pas
je veux pas ta vie je veux que tu vis
pour moi et ça c'est notre mission
après la disparition de leur mère ces
filles décident de prendre le relais
annick à l'aîné est venu avec anthony
ans photographe
leur job fair par les expéditions de
mike et posté un maximum de photos
inédites sur internet maintenant on fait
ce qu'il faut faire c'est jay kay sur
instagram ainsi c'est déjà fait
puis si en fait il faut créer un hashtag
persona aujourd'hui ça sert vraiment
changé la manière de communiquer à
travers d'un style g twitter facebook ça
ça rentre au fait mon travail plus
intéressant parce que je peux partager
l'expérience avec les gens
pour séduire toujours plus de fans l
aventurier partage son quotidien
aujourd'hui
il va se faire photographier à
l'entraînement au menu ce matin la
routine suisse pour mike il part à
l'assaut de la montagne pour se rajouter
de la difficulté il tire profs ne
derrière lui le problème quand on fait
une séance photo avec mike horn c'est
que le shooting prend vite des allures
d'expédition
[Musique]
redresse les roues un arbre bloquent le
passage et rien n'y fait malgré sa
poigne de fer à mains nues il n'y arrive
pas c'est donc la voiture pilotée par sa
fille qui s'en charge
et c'est reparti l'homme est infatigable
c'est un terrain de jeu idéal pour
s'entraîner tu parlais partout tu peux
pas descendre et je remonte la rivière
de soldes se glisse et tombe
je vise
son tour du monde va lui coûter plus de
100000 euros financée par ses sponsors
qui en échange lui demande de
communiquer sur les réseaux sociaux
retour à berlin où mike horn se prêtent
encore une fois au jeu de la séance
photo et comme il ne peut pas s'en
empêcher il va la jouer viril avec les
photographes
[Rires]
c'est pas vrai il m'a cassé la main
mais c'est iron man ce mec tu devrais
avoir ton personnage de super héros
pour raul la star internationale du foot
espagnol il fait la même blague
et son ancien coéquipier en sélection
le champion du monde puyol il ya droit
aussi et ça fait rire tout le monde
ait un regard regarde
[Rires]
c'est un roc ce type
mike horn le survivant n'est pas en
people comme les autres loin des
projecteurs il est reparti pour un
nouveau tour du monde
et il espère bien entré dans la légende
des grands explorateurs